il y a fait des confisans sur son état
d'esprit lorsqu'elle faisait partie de
l'équipe de TP et elle avoué et moi
j'aime bien elle a avoué avoir eu un
moment le melon à part Mathieu Delormeau
qui a déjà eu qui sont qu'il a eu le
melon qui sont qui l'a changé donc
Mathieu tu as toujours eu le Boulard toi
mais c'est pas pareil parce que
contrairement à un petit camarade
j'avais une carrière j'étais connu bien
pardon
de parking je faisais un million
d'audience donc si je l'ai eu c'est
énergie 12 moi ce que je veux dire et tu
parles de qui là de moi
contrairement je n'ai pas eu à TPMP à
NRJ12 j'avoue je l'ai eu qui a le plus
le Boulard autour de la table Mathieu
voulez-vous que je vous raconte
Guillaume j'entends ce qu'il est devenu
depuis qu'il fait la matinale il arrive
une minute avant l'antenne ici il me
regarde il dit ce soir le conducteur de
TPMP nul Cyril va prendre une leçon
demain matin sur Virgin C'est lui c'est
Guillaume Genton ça mais si jamais
tu me dis pas tous les soirs que le
conducteur est nul non c'est toi qui est
nul ça